what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so from this point going forward we are
on the road to Sinestro Corps war which
I'm really really excited about this is
actually it's a really really great
story but again the way that Geoff Johns
does this is just by building up little
tidbits here and there giving us these
little small things these tiny little
things that just sort of pop up from
time to time and we'll actually see that
take place here in this video or at
least the very early days but all kind
of coming together but the idea here is
that we initially pick up one year later
now with regards to the Green Lantern
mythos it's the Green Lantern Corps and
the Green Lantern one year later the
reason why is because of course when we
covered Infinite Crisis following the
conclusion of that story DC sat down and
said look we already have our mainstay
characters basically the people who are
the core members of the Justice League
what we need is to be able to get some
emphasis to either new characters or use
the popularity of Infinite Crisis to
basically bring in a bunch of characters
that normally wouldn't get a whole lot
of representation and give them a chance
to be seen and so what basically
happened is DC release a line of stories
called 52 and it was literally one story
every week and it went on for a full 52
weeks a full calendar year and what we
basically got were all these different
stories involving smaller characters and
showing what they were doing in the year
between the conclusion of Infinite
Crisis and the time the major
superheroes basically return back to the
landscape and so the cool thing is that
with the Green Lantern story and the
Green Lantern core story if we basically
join everything a year later now again a
lot of this was really just kind of how
to sort of talk into different people
and so on and so forth again it's sort
of designed to be an introductory
introductory line of stories but one of
the major emphases that def Jones is
putting here is the fallout of Hal
Jordans time as parallax remember during
the events of the death of Superman
cyborg superman and had basically
destroyed Coast City Hal Jordan came
back from a space mission to find
everything he knew and love completely
obliterated he went insane with madness
and grief declared himself to be
parallax and then just basically started
ripping through and cut a swath through
all the Green Lantern's basically
leading to the introduction of Kyle
Rayner as the last Green Lantern in
existence now that was the official
explanation as it was given by DC during
the events of Emerald Twilight of course
Hal Jordan declaring himself to be
parallax at the time was him just giving
himself a name of course with Geoff
Johns run and one of the things we
talked about recently is that parallax
was an actual entity one of the entities
of the emotional spectrum
represents fear and the result was that
Jeff Johnson ethically came back with a
red Conn and said now during Emerald
Twilight Hal Jordan was literally
possessed by parallax so because of that
it kind of you know bolsters things a
little bit and gives us a pretty solid
point on the character of Hal Jordan
where he's coming from but in terms of
the fallout is John's basically setting
the stage for the return of the
old-school Green Lantern's who were
presumed to have been killed when Hal
Jordan became parallax and destroyed the
Green Lantern Corps and the idea that
there's going to be fallout for the kind
of things that he's done now at this
point we jump over to Sector 674 and
pick up with a guy named arkillo who's
basically told you have the power to
instill great fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps and that
is when the road to assess record war
basically starts this is it this is the
only thing we get with a Sinestro Corps
at least this little segment called
revenge of the Green Lantern's but the
funny thing about this is that when this
story came out and when it was like
welcome to the Sinestro Corps people
freaked I mean I didn't I was reading at
the time I've actually gone back and
look at like old forum posts you know
Wayback Machine different things like
that and people were losing their minds
like they were just speculating all over
the place what does it mean you know
what's gonna happen
it was crazy you know that you know how
people were reacting to all the things
those are the guys who were around when
this story first came out I'm sure you
could attest to the same thing people
were losing their minds they were like
what a Sinestro Corps like it was it was
a crazy crazy thing to go through and
just read people's reactions and see
them kind of going crazy but the
beginning of revenge of the Green
Lantern's who really picks up with the
arrival of tomar to the Green Lantern of
space sector to eight one three who's
one of the original Green Lantern's that
Hal Jordan killed when he was paralyzed
so the first question they have is what
in the world is going on here where did
he come from now what we're going over
here right now is a red car that's
literally recovering at retcon here in
real-time of course those of us who are
new to comedy books retcon means
retroactive continuity is simply that
something happened in a comedy book a
comic book writer comes out comes along
later on down the line and changes what
originally happened and that's what
Geoff Johns was going to be doing here
he's basically going to be retconning
the original Green Lantern's that were
killed by Hal Jordan operating his
parallax and show us that they're
actually alive and so again the cool
thing about this is that back at the the
Green Lantern Corps Citadel basically
you know the the on the planet OA we
basically have Hal Jordan dealing with a
lot of the fallout
to how people view him the reason why is
because of the fact that when the new
Green Lantern Corps was basically being
initiated they were being trained they
were being brought in word began to
spread about what Hal Jordan did when he
was paralyzed that he basically turned
against the Green Lantern Corps and
pushed it to the brink of almost
complete and total extinction and so
because of that a lot of people look at
him as a traitor they still look at him
as somebody who's a liar somebody who
cannot be trusted now this is a
secondhand viewpoint right it's like if
I tell you something and then you take
it as gospel truth you believe it
because I told you not because you know
it to be true and so because of that
these guys are basically just kind of
going on what it is they've been told by
other people it's secondhand knowledge
at best and so again it kind of creates
an interesting scenario because what it
does is it basically has geoff johns
showing us what their allegiance to the
core really means despite the fact that
it's second-hand knowledge despite the
fact that they don't know that it's true
their allegiance to the Green Lantern
Corps means that they view Hal Jordan as
a traitor now the other half of this is
that they're also in fear for their own
lives now they're not they don't really
come out and show that instead what we
end up having are individuals who have
basically taken up the mantle of Green
Lantern for other people who were the
Green Lantern other sector before Howard
until them for example one of the guys
at a tactile Jordan is basically the
next person to become Green Lantern
after their predecessor kiha I think is
how you pronounce it was supposedly
killed by Hal Jordan and so a lot of
these guys are swearing revenge they're
saying look the Green Lantern of my
sector was killed by you
I'm the new Green Lantern and now you're
gonna die at the very least they're
gonna be the absolute hell out of them
now of course Guy Gardner steps in right
and this is my fans love Guy Gardner
because guy gardeners like to come on
man like you're killing me you really
think you stand a chance that's why
people love guy gardeners because he's
so cocky he's so arrogant but he's got
it where it counts let's do some some
some guy gardener fans are feeling
hardened they're like damn right Rob he
does have it worked out and I'm sure
sweet folks are just like yeah man but
uh but the fact remains here that once
the entire conflict is basically quelled
by by Kilowog we end up having Hal
Jordan meeting with the guardians of the
universe now of course pal Jordan's
response here is hey look
tomar two basically arrived here he's
supposed to have been dead the fact that
he's alive means an investigation needs
to be launched of course the guardians
of the universe are well aware of the
fact that home r2 is alive but this is
Geoff Johns kind of dipping into the
idea that the guardians of the universe
are a
duplicitous they're not completely
honest with the Green Lanterns now it
makes sense right I mean when you're the
President of the United States you don't
tell the American people everything
that's going on because they don't need
to know everything that's going on and
even if they did of what use would that
information be to them you tell people
what they need to know and you let the
press deal with everything else the
press are the ones that disseminate that
information they give people what it is
it's going on but if you're sitting with
the president needs to say look we're in
the Situation Room we have this this
business and this all going on you're
going to be overloaded with information
we're asked when you're given that
information contextually based on this
situation that you're in then you can
absorb it and you can use it for what
it's worth as opposed to just kind of
letting it sit in your brain and then
pass you by so again it's not really
keeping people from getting any
information that they need it's making
sure they get the information at the
right time but it presents a very
dangerous situation because if I'm a
holder of the keys and I'm guarding all
the doors you can only get in if I'd let
you well then what happens if I don't
want to let you in well then you can't
access whatever is on the other side
information is the exact same way and so
again it's basically us is you know
readers learning that the guardians of
the universe are holding information but
the fact that they're not benign the
fact that they are for the most part a
little mysterious they're very
cloak-and-dagger in terms of how they
deal with the Green Lantern's it means
that they're not giving out the
essential information that's necessary
now with regards to Hal Jordan his
request for an investigation of what's
going on with regards to the
re-emergence of tomar tube is
immediately declined it's immediately
turned down the Guardians are like nope
you do not need to you do not need to do
that simply because of the fact that the
the destination of tomar 2 was traced
back to his intention to arrive on earth
but having originated beyond sector 3600
now being beyond that sector 3600
basically means you beyond known space
and if I understand it correctly you're
getting into the realm of what was
basically beyond the source wall or just
at the source wall effectively you're
outside the patrolling area of the
guardians of the universe and so because
of that they basically say it's beyond
our sector beyond our ability to
basically function out there you know
you do not go there not only that the
Manhunters occupy that space out there
and of course the Guardians basically
say the reason why is because of the
fact that the Manhunters were able to
exist in that area because nothing can
survive out there no organic organism
can survive on its own now of course we
end up having
Jorden and Guy Gardner take off anyway
because what kind of green lantern's
would they be if they always follow the
rules and so again it's kind of a it's
kind of a funny scenario but it's also
how's your Dean you know basically lying
saying hey look a man of course the
guardians of the universe sanction this
mission what wouldn't a I'm missing
Green Lantern comes back and they want
to know what happened of course guy
gardeners along for the ride now we as
fans know Guy Gardner was born at night
but he wasn't born last night so he's
well aware what's going on with regards
to what house you were telling him the
problem is that when they arrive to
where it was that Tomar two had
originated from they just find a massive
amount of Manhunters I mean literally
just thousands of Manhunters all over
the place almost like a base of
operations or a giant factory cranking
them out and that's exactly what this is
it's basically a factory cranking out
all these different Manhunters now these
are the ones that we had seen in Green
Lantern no fear in Volume one when we
had this newest iteration of Manhunter
whose head was basically a central power
battery I guess a power battery of sorts
and function for the purpose of
absorbing green lantern energy and so
for this reason with only Hal Jordan and
Guy Gardner being here they're on the
ropes and they constantly have to race
against the clock because if they spend
more than a couple seconds in front of
one of these one of these man hunters
their rings are going to lose their
charge and they're going to be
completely defenseless and so while
they're on their way to basically racing
the safety trying to find a place where
they can recoup where they can basically
regain their energies allow their rings
to charge and jump back into the fray
they end up coming across the bodies of
some of the most prominent Green
Lantern's that were killed by Hal Jordan
himself when he was parallax of course
all this is revealed to have been
orchestrated by cyborg superman by hank
henshaw
now what this does is it requires us to
kind of sidetrack for a little bit and
it requires us to actually jump back to
a story in 1996 I think it was called
final night and what final night did is
it basically kind of detailed the last
little tidbit of house word and parallax
with regards to you know the Prix Geoff
Johns run on Green Lantern and what we
basically found out here was that
because cyborg superman alongside
mongrel had obliterated the entirety of
Coast City leading to I think I said
Central City earlier but they rated the
entirety of Coast City leading to Hal
Jordan becoming parallax in the first
place despite all the things that he had
done Hal Jordan looked at cyborg
superman as the one guy he needed to get
revenge on and so basically heat
at the edge of the universe basically
obliterated of cyborg superman using his
constructs and that was the end of him
now there was a little segment with like
superman red superman blue where they
met cyborg superman and so on and so
forth we don't need to worry about that
that was not very good storytelling but
with regards to what it is a Geoff Johns
is doing here this is when the retcon
begins to come into play because what
we're basically told is that after
having basically destroyed the body of
cyborg superman during final night that
he reconstituted his physical body but
the result is that he also came across
the Manhunters their programming what it
was designed for and effectively
modified them so for those of you guys
who have been huge fans of Marvel Comics
and who are reading anihilation conquest
think about annihilation conquest
basically being the same thing as this
of course this comes long before
conquest but the fact remains think of
them as basically being almost identical
and annihilation conquest
Ultron's physical body was destroyed his
consciousness took over the Phalanx and
he basically began constructing an
empire that's exactly what's happening
here with cyborg Superman now the idea
here is that this is Geoff Johns
basically teasing the whole the whole
concept of Hal Jordan being pure
willpower now of course this is
something that won't really be explored
until we get to like Robert vendetta's
run with Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern's as part of DC rebirth but it
was basically the case that Geoff Johns
was making the entire time no Green
Lantern will ever be as capable as Hal
Jordan at least as is being portrayed
here now the great thing is that Geoff
Johns was going to grow and he's going
to expand the Green Lantern's and so
we're going to see characters playing
some pretty significant roles and
everybody's going to get their chance
everybody's going to get their their
time in the Sun guy gardener Kyle Rayner
Jon Stewart all these different versions
they're all going to get their time in
the Sun so again it's going to be pretty
cool so you have to see this light shine
on everybody the issue with this is that
when house were basically overcomes the
attempt of cyborg superman to override
his brain using you know nanites to
basically hook him up to a machine and
siphon off his his Green Lantern energy
his willpower Hal Jordan basically wakes
up key han this Green Lantern that we
thought had since been destroyed now the
funny thing is that in the moment Jihan
basically sees Manhunters and just
starts tearing things up but then how
Jordan starts going through and waking
up all of these different individuals
Lyra for example and chants and you know
racked horn and and and Vedika I think
it is how you pronounce it I'm not 100%
sure but begins waking up all these
different Green Lantern's to be ish
is that once the immediate threat of the
Manhunters is taken care of at least
temporarily they immediately attack Hal
Jordan and the reason why is because for
them time hasn't passed from the time
that they had essentially died
quote-unquote until the time they woke
up here it was moments it was like if
you blinked your eyes or like if you
fell asleep or something like that no
time has passed for them as far as they
know how Jordan is still paralyzed so
they're living there basically still
living in 1993-94 Emerald Twilight and
the idea that Hal Jordan is a bad guy
and trying to attack them now of course
all this begins to more or less wind
down when torn basically says guys stop
if Hal Jordan was still parallax he
would have killed us all by now
the fact that he's not fighting is an
indication that something else is going
on here so this is when the air is
cleared slightly and he basically tells
them hey look you guys have been here
for years now of course they still don't
trust it they still do not trust Hal
Jordan and there's no reason for them to
but it's basically a scenario of the
enemy of my enemy is my friend in the
sense that they're temporary allies of
Hal Jordan because it's in their best
interest to work together to defeat
cyborg superman and the Manhunters after
which someone is going to pay in spades
so what we also end up doing here is we
basically pick up with the return of a
character named arisia at least I think
it's ERISA or aresia we're going to call
our arisia so I think it's a much better
like a cool way to save her name but not
only is she prevalent here but there's
also a litany of Green Lantern's a
multitude of individuals who have just
gone missing over the years or whatever
the case may be and so of course in the
middle of these old-school lanterns what
we're going to call them in the middle
of these old-school lanterns basically
realizing that so many other lanterns
are here the entire group is basically
attacked by Guy Gardner who's been
pulled and and basically attached to the
inside of a of a giant Manhunter robot
so again this shows us what the goal of
cyborg superman is to essentially
harness
Green Lantern's use their energy use
them as literal batteries to power these
massive devices that he's made for
himself and begin the process of
universal conquest not from here
Geoff Johns and this was really the only
time I know of where he really seems to
invoke this lease on what I've read so
far but Geoff Johns really just kind of
invokes this easy way out retcon
Geoff Johns I love you man I love
everything you do and and man I'd love
to get something signed by you one day
but it's got to crack me up when I saw
this because it was like well I mean
like cyborgs
basically says well you know whenever
they're in a state of duress whenever
they are basically you know what they're
considered to have been dead uh
individuals from from Braxton or really
from that from the Braxton territories
those individuals basically go through
and they experience the equivalent of a
Kryptonian a healing chroma that's
really what they end up going through um
it's kind of funny to see that
juxtaposition between you know what Jess
Jones was doing here and the return of
Superman the difference is that most
people in fact a lot of people did not
give DC a pass when it came to the
return of Superman but they give Jeff
Jones a pass when it came to the Green
Lantern now I would surmise this is
really because of the fact that it's not
a plot device it's actually designed to
basically give us something that we
wouldn't normally get or something
that's intriguing because the survival
of arisia is not important to the story
by any standard of measurement she could
not be here she could still be dead and
the story would continue on just fine
it's not like Jeff Jones backed himself
into a wall and needed an easy way out
it's not like that at all instead aresia
is an intrinsic part of the Hal Jordan
landscape in the sense that the two of
them were lovers for quite some time now
of course falling Hal Jordan becoming
parallax the last big leaf so to speak
was the fact that a ryssia basically
said hey look he will come back like he
will come back to his normal self now of
course the shoot was killed by major
force who in turn was killed by Guy
Gardner but the fact remains here that
her return means that there's somebody
out there who sees redemption for Hal
Jordan and that's why this is important
Guy Gardner will always be in his corner
no matter what happens you know Jon
Stewart will always be a friend of Hal
Jordan I mean I wouldn't say that he'll
be in his corner no matter what I mean
he'll come a point where Jon Stewart's
like okay look how like you got a dime
and like this is not okay but erisa was
the one who always had faith in health
that he would always come back she's the
bright shining star in his life so this
is basically Jeff Jon bring her back and
saying hey look guys it's not bleak it's
not dark it's not hopeless we need to
have some hope in what's going on in the
Green Lantern landscape especially with
the stories that are getting ready to
come up so again you know this bits fly
between Cyborg Superman and Hal Jordan
is relatively short-lived in the sense
that where Hank Henshaw initially gets
the upper hand
Larissa's ring activates she jumps back
into the fray and the two of them start
facing off against Hank Henshaw who is
basically believed to have been
destroyed but the fact remains here that
with the with the central core basically
at this planet being destroyed the
planet itself
basically explodes is completely and
totally eradicated and so jumping back
to the citadel of the guardians on OA
we of course have Guy Gardner covering
for how Gardner is of course he's since
been made a member of the honor guard in
the Green Lantern Corps and because of
that he's allowed three strikes until he
loses his position and is possibly even
banned from the Green Lantern Corps so
because of this he basically just takes
one of his lifelines he says yeah man
like I gave him permission to go on this
mission of course it was an area was my
mistake two more shots and then I'll be
done so you know just don't worry about
that then but the problem is he still
has to be punished and so because of
that he's assigned to basically spend
time a month on prime duty and what that
means if he's going to be one of the
guys who guards superboy-prime in a
science sell day in and day out every
day for one month so it's gonna it's
gonna suck it is a really crappy job but
again this is basically Jeff Shawn
saying hey guys let's we forget
superboy-prime is still there
superboy-prime is still being held by
the Green Lantern's and the reason why
is because as we know with Sinestro
Corps war superboy-prime is going to
come back when that being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come and
explain make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the robb cork
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]